Where do we find clues as to how our cancer is driven?
Is it in the initial cheek swab?
Yes.
A resulting program?
No. Well, we're talking about the right program.
No, you won't see if you're going to get a clue of that.
Or do we get the info from the genetic report?
No. So, depending on when you started with us,
we used to be very open about the causes.
We have causes, balancers, and then food drivers.
It's just when we got attacked by the AMA,
then we had to be careful with our terminology.
So, we had to kind of take that terminology out
that what caused the cause and what was the driver's.
We had to be more careful with that terminology.
But I've had a point right now.
I just don't care.
They could just throw it at you.
I just don't care anymore.
So, when you look at diet,
so when you talk about what is our cancer is driven,
let's clarify that phrase.
So, cancer could be caused from something.
So, anything that gets inside of a cell,
that damages the nucleus at the DNA,
the replication cycle, and the cell goes into rapid replication.
That is the initial cause of the cancer.
And you could move us to find it out to help deal with that.
So, it doesn't cause the same thing in another cell.
Now, understand, even if you could magically make that all go away.
Let's say if the cause that got inside the cell,
that damaged the DNA,
that caused it to go into rapid replication,
let's pretend it was a microtoxic.
If you could magically remove all the microtoxics from your body,
it still doesn't solve the problem
that the cells are still in rapid replication,
because the damage was done.
But, if you get rid of that,
we know that your body is susceptible to microtoxics
as a cause of cancer.
We don't want it to cause another cancer or cancer somewhere else.
So, it's essential in mind to find out what that causes
and deal with that.
And deal with other potential causes,
other toxins, other biotoxics.
That's why we do that testing.
We want to deal with all the polarities.
That's why I talked about autoimmune diseases
and deal with those polarities
that could be causes of cancer.
Secondly, a driver of cancer could be a term that we use
to what is fueling the cancer.
So, remember, a cells that are in rapid replication
are very hungry.
So, hungry cells need a fuel source.
That's why we take you off of certain things.
Dairy is a pelvic fuel source.
That's why I recommend everybody with cancer
go on a lower sugar diet
and keep it your glucose levels.
If you test them with a glucometer,
a low range will also be helpful.
Does it mean everybody needs to go ketogenic?
Doesn't mean everybody needs to do anything specifically.
We want to test for what are fuel sources.
That can change.
So, in cheek swab testing,
if that changes, I make that note and tell you,
stay off of this food too, you know,
change your diet, I make those changes.
So, that's all done, that is all done on the cheek swab.
So, if, you know,
we always recheck that driver.
So, you know, capric requests thing.
Originally, dairy was a driver.
The diets had no dairy.
This cheek swab dairy was not a drive note.
So, I don't rephrase it.
So, if I say there's a different driver than, yes.
So, if I don't tell you again that dairy is a driver,
I only make changes on the cheek swab.
So, when I said you back information on the cheek swab,
it's just that any changes.
So, stay as dairy free as possible.
But that brings up another question.
Can I ever just relax a bit on the driver?
And the answer is always yes.
So, if you've eliminated, you know,
a main fuel source for a period of time,
is it okay to have water once in a while?
Or is it okay to put some cream in like coffee
a few times a week?
The answer is yes, always has been yes.
Because you're never going to completely eliminate
the fuel source.
So, that's kind of a foul.
So, you're never going to be able to completely eliminate it.
So, and I also have always said this is a diet.
It's not a dogma, it's not a religion.
You're not, you know, first,
but you're not sitting by, you know,
having some butter on your toast or something like that.
So, just make sure it ends.
I will say also that it can be dangerous
to even have that thought in your mind
because that is producing anxiety.
And what does anxiety do,
but stimulates a sympathetic reaction,
which can be the worst thing for your cancer.
And I've said over and over, you know,
a hundred times, it's a lot of times
the people that do the best amount of cancer
and end up having the best success
and the people that are just like,
ah, tell me what to do.
I'll do the best I can
and I'm going to leave the results to go.
The ones that are frantic and anxious and worried
and concerned and analyzing everything
and getting, you know, having OCD issues about their cancer.
Again, the problem with that is it stimulates,
glutamate, it stimulates sympathetic dominance.
It shuts down your immune system
and it shuts down your detoxification pathways.
All those things are not good.
So, don't ever beat yourself out about,
you know, I don't like goodness, it was by, you know,
suns birthday or something and it'll hand a bite of cake.
Maybe let's all go to the cake.
It's not a scene.
That's not how we're supposed to even act with spiritual things.
Not only spirit doesn't beat you well,
but you make a mistake.
She molds you, shapes you.
Sometimes that's not pleasant,
but he's gentle and graceful and merciful and done.
And that's the way you need to be,